[Musique]
oh
pour ces vacances
[Musique]
[Rires]
certains cas
rappaz
dans la danse la maman dans la lah
[Musique]
patrick regard ils se transforment en de
petites oreilles damas et oui on
m'appelle peu dans la main il encore de
petits lapins vaches alain thirel
tiffert se nomme du vrai mais j'ai eu
très bonne et de lapin en rien qui dit
gros chien ce sont des gaules un regard
l'inde elle est placée par la main
l'autre né dans notre main abracadabra
elle se basait mais ce n'est pas tout
car maintenant il faut que tu as any
antunes propriétés magiques qui paraît
si je bouge aller de 20 lots
regarde par l'autre sainte
[Musique]
des nids dans attention pas le doigt
seulement le nez et maintenant je n'ai
dans ma main deux passes dans la bouche
regard
voilà c'est de la reprend les dans la
bouche voilà et j'ai inventé une autre
1 et de la page
mais attention up
passé
on voit la bouche
et voilà tous deux membres tu as trois
très bonnes et les biens des trois
bonnes et je vais maintenant les placer
dans la main oulala pas facile hein
parce qu'ils sont très gros mais en
faisant juste un deux trois six et
roanne et se transforme en un immense
neergaard raddad rue on va chercher qui
qu'apple a vendu unis
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
il
là
mais
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
et
oh
non
[Musique]
oh
et
et maintenant ça va être le truc encore
un truc aussi qu'alors avec une pièce
demain une petite piège de 1 france
n'ont pas d'importance d'ailleurs avec
un front peut faire un très joli tour
regarder la ds est mise dans un petit
papier ferme ce petit papier là
maintenant un autre pas fier je n'ai
aujourd'hui on se sert beaucoup de
fatigue il m'apprend papier bleu vous
donnera toutes les couleurs voilà si
l'on sait pas on fait abracadabra et
attention on rouvre cette fois c'est une
surprise parce qu'au milieu
la pièce de monnaie a fondu essai
transformé
on dirait presque du sel ainsi du sucre
cedus 8 on va goûter non celle du sel et
bien ya bien sûr une petite préparation
je regrette mais alors là je crois que
vous en sortirez très bien il ya 1,5
d'un petit papier du gris par exemple
deux autres un petit peu plus grand
violet pourquoi par l'incroyable fois
qu'on allait payer tous de la même façon
comme ceux ci en trois dans un sens et
dans l'autre sens quand vous savez ça
vous savez tout faire il faut ensuite au
milieu on colle vous voyez ici c'est de
l'art est ainsi si on a bien collé on
obtient deux compartiments secrets
si le truc et oui elle a alors d'un côté
on va placer le petit sachet qui
contient du sel parce qu'il faut du sel
voilà on met du sel très bien quand on a
bien découpé évidemment on le met
si avec son enseigne en fer et de
l'autre côté on nous et on a au milieu
un petit papier vide en ne mettant
encore la pièce le tout est mis ici dans
le papier bleu la pièce est là on est
prêt à démarrer
c'est david tu veux nous montrer il va
le faire or la perte d'un mois on
regarde la colle puisque tu étais en
train d'essayer de le fabriquer toi
aussi
voilà essaie de le faire montre le bien
pour nos amis tu te tiens bien parce que
pour pas que ça souvent tu es là tu vois
que tu as du sel danse et du sucre non
recherche sur halo
[Musique]
élu
à
[Musique]
on
à
qu'est ce que tu fais électrique autant
que je cherche un déclic
ah non non non là c'est le classique
mais donc pas un clic
le déclic tête à claques au robinet à
temps c'est pas net
tu vois là un tirage aussi coton doux
vers girard je me propose une photo
surprise avec vous deux ah si c'est ici
et là surprise c'est un petit oiseau
j'y crois pas du tout à jouer nature
gérard un petit oiseau
vous allez voir vous allez on essaie
tech sur le petit bonhomme on regarde
l'appareil très très bien attention clic
clac
merci ma chatte et voilà le petit oiseau
alors que madame anne oiseaux une photo
une photo à la maison alors une photo
voie d'accord on la sent place pour la
photo
regardez girard qu'est ce que c'est que
ça c'est une carotte pour attraper les
grands lacs
[Musique]
ça va être la surprise
3 qu'est ce que vous avez encore faim
c'est la photo / heureusement que
celui-là
abracadabra il faut le délivrer
à l'approché toi
[Musique]